-Hi, Shepard.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
-What's up, man?
A creative name, right?
"The News." A lot of thought.
-I love --
-How did you get the rights
to just calling it "The News"?
It's genius.
-Many focus groups, man.
Just, you know -- These things
come if you take time.
-Welcome to the NBC family.
We're excited to have you
at the network.
You're at CNBC right now?
-Yep.
-You are the first interview
not on Zoom
that I've done in six months
since we've been in quarantine,
so thank you for doing this.
This is really cool for me.
-I'm happy to do it.
But back when
you were in quarantine
and your kids
took over for The Roots,
those were great shows, man.
I loved those
sitting at home in the box.
That was a lot of fun.
-Oh, I'm happy.
Thank you.
Yeah, they stole the show.
I had to push them off
a little bit.
They were getting
too big-headed.
I want to ask you about a couple
things from over the weekend.
Obviously "The Times" obtained
Trump's tax information.
Can you tell us about that
and what is that news?
Explain the big takeaway there.
-We haven't confirmed it at
CNBC, but from the reporting,
I feel like
what stuck out for me was
he spent 70 grand on hair
for television.
I'm not sure
that there was great value.
But, seriously, you know,
11 of the last 18 years,
according to
"The Times'" reporting,
he didn't -- he avoided
paying taxes at all.
-Yeah.
-He had a lot more dealings
with special-interest groups
in the United States
and overseas
than we knew
before this reporting,
though there's nothing new
on any Russian parts of it all.
We know that Ivanka was
receiving some consulting money
that cut down on his taxes.
And, you know, there was a lot
of that sort of thing.
What does it all add up to?
I'm not sure it'll matter
to his faithful.
The Never Trumpers
are still Never Trumpers.
And whether the people in
the middle pay attention to that
or not, I don't know.
But "The Times" says there's
more investigating coming
and more reports,
so we'll watch for it.
-Yeah.
Well, obviously the sad news
that Ruth Bader Ginsburg
passed away.
And over the weekend,
Trump nominated conservative
Amy Coney Barrett
to the Supreme Court.
And he says that he wants her
to be confirmed
before the election.
Do you think
that's going to happen?
-It could.
They say it's going to happen,
that they can make it happen
in that amount of time.
She's the darling
of conservatives.
The evangelical crew loves her.
He wants -- He's been talking
from the very beginning
about how judges
will be his legacy.
And whether it'll affect
the election or not,
it probably will.
You just don't know which way
it's going to play, Jimmy.
You know, will conservatives
be so happy about it
that they come out
and vote for more
or will Democrats
and people on the left say,
"We can't let this
happen again,"
and come out and vote
in bigger numbers?
I don't think we'll know
till we know.
-Yeah. Trump is now
questioning the election --
the validity of the election
should he lose.
-Well, of this, I'm certain.
There is nothing to indicate
that there's
widespread voter fraud
on a local level
or on the national level.
That's reportable,
and that's factual.
The rest of it,
I'm not exactly sure
what it is
he's trying to accomplish.
Because there is
no evidence of that.
I'm sure that
there's some thinking
that if it doesn't go well maybe
he'll be able to point to that.
He made these same sorts
of accusations
before the last election
regarding Hillary Clinton.
So sometimes you have to
just watch what's happening
and listen to what they're
saying just a little bit less.
Not just the President,
but most of them, Jimmy.
-Yeah. Maybe he's just trying
to hype up his base and be like,
"Yeah, it's going to be rigged,
so you better get out there
and vote because
it's going to be rigged,
and if we just win
by a landslide,
then we won't have to have
this conversation."
-And, also, "If I don't win,
here might be the reason."
He's managed expectations
in this way
throughout his business career.
You wonder if maybe he's
taking a page from that now.
I don't know.
-The first presidential debate
is tomorrow night.
It is going to be moderated
by your former
Fox News colleague
Chris Wallace.
What do you expect to see
in the debate tomorrow night?
What should we expect?
-I expect Chris Wallace
to be prepared.
Nobody who has watched
Chris Wallace
thinks other than
that he's a very tough,
very thoroughly prepared
journalist.
And he's said repeatedly
over the years,
to me and publicly,
"My job is to
stay out of the way
and be unnoticed
as much as possible."
But he's not one to let a
falsehood or a misrepresentation
or a "look over here"
kind of shiny object thing
just slide by the way.
He will hold them.
Both of them.
He's not a partisan guy.
He's searching for truth.
He's trying
to speak truth to power
and trying to get information
to the public.
That's what all journalists
want to do.
It's not about Chris.
He'll be the first
to tell you that.
It's about finding out
what they are really about.
-That's a good segue
into your new show.
You certainly couldn't have
picked a more critical time
in our nation's history
to start your new show.
There's so much news to cover.
Tell us about "The News
with Shepard Smith."
-It'll be that simple.
It'll be the news.
We're not going to have pundits.
We're not going to have opinion.
We'll bring you facts.
The facts, the truth, the news.
We'll try to bring it to you
in context and with perspective.
When we see things that are not
true, like that shiny object
I was talking about,
we'll point that out.
And we'll cut through
the disinformation.
Jimmy, there's so much of it.
It's all over our feeds.
Sometimes people live
in a world of just lies.
And when that's happening
and it rises to the public
discourse, we'll point it out.
Look, there was a time
when all newscasts
or most of them were just,
"Here are the facts,
so you can decide for yourself.
Here's what's happening
in the world
so you can plan
for your family
and your business and
your community and your church."
That's what we want to do.
We want to be a source
of truth and honesty,
and we'll hold truth to power
because that is our job.
The founding fathers
didn't only put journalism
in the Constitution
for no reason.
They put it there
because it's important,
and journalists have
a responsibility to get it right
and tell it straight, and
that's what we're going to do.
-It premiers this Wednesday
at 7:00 p.m.
You're going to be on
every night.
Congrats on this and good luck
with the new show.
I'll be watching.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
Really appreciate it.
-Thanks again for coming
on the show. Stay safe, please.
Shepard Smith, everybody.
"The News with Shepard Smith"
premiers this Wednesday
at 7:00 p.m. on CNBC.
Set your DVRs.